Star Wars Jedi Survivor Builds on the
already winning formula of Star Wars
Jedi Fallen order by making kalcastis a
more powerful and resourceful Jedi
Knight while also upping the stakes and
the challenges he's facing exhilarating
lightsaber combat and physics-defying
platforming puzzle challenges Remain the
best part of respawn's latest Star Wars
game but Survivor also makes big Swings
with its story this time around Cal's
Quest takes him to new corners of the
Galaxy but the most compelling Journey
he makes is an introspective One
Survivor is a very well written tale
about overcoming fear and it's the Jedi
story I've wanted for a long time
Survivor takes place about five years
after the events of Fallen order with
the Mantis crew having gone their
separate ways to pursue different goals
in a galaxy increasingly dominated by
the Galactic Empire after a daring
escape from Imperial authorities
protagonist Cal finds himself in the
planet Kobo where he discovers a high
Republic Jedi protocol Droid who carries
a clue to reaching Tana law a supposedly
unreachable mythical Planet seeing a
potential home that's free of the
Empire's influence Cal sets about
reassembling the mantis crew for another
Galactic scavenger hunt but his efforts
are waylaid by a former High Republic
Jedi who having originally discovered
tanalore decades prior and bid his time
until the right moment once tanelor for
his own purposes the high Republic is a
fascinating time period for Survivor to
connect its story to given what we know
has transpired between that era and the
events of post Revenge of the Sith
Survivor explores the concept of fear
and what it means for someone like Cal a
survivor of both a war and a genocidal
attack on his people to live with the
ever-present shadow of fear as a
survivor of the Jedi Order Cal fears
failing to live up to its ideals
compelling him to go to unhealthy
Extremes in his fight against the empire
all the while he pushes down the growing
sentiment he feels for those he loves in
order to avoid painful rejection while
the theme of fear and how it can change
you is Central to Cal's story survivor's
main antagonists also benefit from this
Focus transforming into foils for Cal to
reflect on his actions on their own the
two big bads lack the level of nuanced
characterization I want from a villain
in the end both boil down to being evil
because they're selfish albeit in
different ways it's not exactly
compelling when compared to Fallen
orders terrifying and yet understandably
tragic second sister but as foils for
Cal survivor's villains catalyze his
gross first forcing him to come to terms
with how his Reckless pursuit of
destroying the Empire and reaching Tana
law could culminate in his own fall to
the dark side if he's not careful and
second recognizing The Importance of
Being a new type of Jedi for a chance
Galaxy we've seen variations of these
transformations in Jedi before Luke
Skywalker and Ahsoka Tano being the two
major examples in the current Canon but
in Cal's Journey respawn delves even
deeper into what it means for a Jedi
grappling with the doubts and
insecurities that everyday people in the
Star Wars Universe navigate all the time
as a result Cal's conflict with
survivor's villains sees him regularly
teachering towards the dark side more
than typical Star Wars protagonist safer
Anakin Skywalker obviously leaving you
guessing up until the final fight of the
game as to where Cal's moral compass is
eventually going to align that seesaw
ride is so poignant because Survivor
story gives cow a lot to care about and
isn't afraid to see him lose it during
crucial narrative beats the narrative
incentive of Survivor isn't our desire
to see the good guys win it's to explore
just how much the good guys are willing
to throw away on that path to Victory
while these new personal challenges
require a great deal of growth from Cal
to Grapple with the more immediate
physical challenges rely on a familiar
set of skills and abilities Survivor
smartly avoids the pitfall of depowering
its protagonist meaning Cal starts off
with the lightsaber and traversal
abilities he earned during Fallen order
against the weaker foes of the early
game cow already feels substantially
dominant as a seasoned Jedi that has
been fighting for survival should be you
are empowered to slice through simple
Stormtroopers and perform
force-propelled parkour across
Bottomless Pits with ease these skills
don't mean cow is all powerful though
and after an exciting opening chapter
Survivor puts you in your place with an
assortment of challenging new enemy
types this encourages you to spend your
points wisely in survivor's branching
skill tree to unlock new powers much
like Fallen order survivors combat
primarily relies on Cal's lightsaber
slicing through an enemy guard and
paring their strikes until their stamina
gives out so you can land in some solid
hits it's much easier to discern
incoming attacks from fake outs or
preempts of windups in Survivor compared
to Fallen order and Cal's moves feel
sharper and quicker this time around too
this affords you more Control In the
Heat of battle and helps the game's
mostly fast-paced fights feel more
surmountable when an enemy gets a hit in
it now feels more like your mistake and
not a stroke of bad luck where the glow
of Cal's lightsaber and particle effects
of an enemy's weapon muddied the visual
language of the Parry mechanic Cal has
his own stamina meter to worry about so
combat is as much about control and
careful timing as it is about being
strategically aggressive each battle
plays out as a cerebral exercise The
Experience evolves into an exciting flow
as you get the hang of it all of which
is captured with Incredible audio detail
each carefully deflected Blaster bolt
resounds with that distinctive Star Wars
ping
the bd1 is still your regular companion
who keeps you healed up and unlocks
doors Cal is joined by other characters
During certain parts of the story too
either the Blaster toting Bode or
sorcery wielding Marin joins Cal in
certain story missions to help him deal
with tougher fights neither one adds
anything especially noteworthy to the
experience of combat but they are a
welcome resource for crowd control in
the tough as Nails fights in the latter
half of the game and their tag team
takedowns with Cal are all visual
Delights
foreign
to go along with the idea that he's now
older and more skilled Cal also gets two
new lightsaber stances in Survivor
Blaster and crossgard the former offers
Cal arranged fighting style while the
latter deals in slow but heavy attacks
both have their advantages but Blaster
feels a lot better in motion matching
the other three Styles and sense of
speed Survivor limits you to only having
two lightsaber Styles equipped at a time
forcing you to visit a meditation Circle
checkpoint in order to change them at
times this restriction can feel
frustrating as it funnels how you spend
your skill points into the two Styles
you ultimately end up using most often
thereby discouraging experimentation
while I initially found this stifling I
came to appreciate how the limitation
forced me to adapt to where I did
allocate my skill points especially when
it came to lightsaber stances each style
has its own unique strengths and
weaknesses so you can curate your own
take on how Cal fights you decide where
Cal falls short crowd control for
example or maybe all-out attack power
and and get creative in how you overcome
that weakness platforming challenges and
force puzzles return in Survivor as well
like combat both feel better in Survivor
in comparison to Fallen order Kell
automatically latches onto climbable
surfaces now and a healthy assortment of
unlockable shortcuts means that
accidentally missing a jump Midway
through an action set piece likely won't
set you back too far the game makes time
for Quiet Moments too best seen in
another of survivor's major new features
a hub-like area that Cal can return to
frequently on Kobo calcan visitor
Cantina that fills with NPCs you've
saved on your travels across the Galaxy
some of these characters act as vendors
selling Cal Cosmetics or optional
gameplay perks others help Cal liven up
the Cantina with music or a rooftop
garden the best of them act as Quest
givers pointing Cal towards the puzzle
boxes that are high Republic vaults
bounty hunter minibosses or more
recruitable NPCs even if the characters
themselves are for the most part
narratively flat and boring to talk to
the perks they sell are rewarding and
the missions they give are often fun to
complete on a final note survivor's
technical performance is a stumbling
block that must be noted playing on Xbox
series X I experienced random crashes on
a number of occasions all annoyingly
during cut scenes before the game had a
chance to auto save on one unlucky and
deeply frustrating occasion the game
crashed during the cutscene following an
especially challenging multi-phase boss
battle that had taken me many attempts
to finally beat because of the crash my
progress was lost and I had to fight the
boss a half more dozen times again to
beat him on PlayStation 5 one colleague
reported some occasional stuttering
screen tearing and crashing too while
another co-worker had an important
cutscene ruined by one character rubber
band glitching around the screen the PC
version 2 also has a variety of
technical issues relating to in-game
presentation performance and Hardware
optimization the script for this video
was written before the day one patch
drop so have to see if all of these
issues were addressed by that
Survivor Builds on Fallen order in
several meaningful ways tightening up
the combat mechanics expanding the
variety of lightsaber Styles alleviating
the frustration of platforming and
puzzles and digging into less mainstream
Star Wars lore to tell a fantastic story
about a Jedi trying to defeat a
tyrannical evil at all costs and coming
to the realization that you can't just
fight for good you have to fight for
good in the right way it's a superb Star
Wars game that gets into the
nitty-gritty of the struggle of what it
takes for a Jedi Knight to begin the
journey towards the rank of Master
inside